this is the perfect course if you want
to improve your skills with angular
you will learn to create a project from
scratch using a public api
slobodan who created this course is very
experienced
and he's worked at many top companies in
this tutorial
i'm building an angular application from
scratch and i'm using public api to
create
this interesting game database website i
will show you how to set up a project
using angular cli
how to create components how to make
http calls how to
implement http interceptors how to make
services
also you will learn how to set up routes
for your application
how to pass data with routes in between
the components
we will use pipes for data formatting
various angular directives like ng4 and
ngif
and so much more so stay until end of it
and you'll be in a good place to have a
great foundation
for building angular applications
for project setup i'm gonna be using for
this angular cli
so for generating all the components
it's going to be angle cli
and npm packages for others so first i'm
gonna
name our project ng video game
db stands for database and i'm going to
set the style
to be scss because i like using more css
for our stylings i'll skip strict
checking
for this project right now but i would
like to add the angular routing
now the project creation has been done
successfully we want to head over into
our root
folder of our application which is ng
video game db
and the first package which i want to
add is angular material
i will add all the packages at the
beginning and import them into our
application so
that later on we can focus on
just coding type ng add angular material
for material pre-built theme you can use
whatever you want i'm going to use the
second one in this
list and i want
angle material to set up the typography
styles and to set up the animations for
our
angular material and the last package
which i want to add to our
project is angular gadge this plugin i
will be using for
displaying the rating of our games
so just type in npm i angular
gadge and now when we successfully
install all these packages we want to
import
them inside of the app.module.ts
first i want to import the angular
modules forms module and http client
module
next are the modules from the external
packages like gadge module
then we will import the angular material
modules we will need mat tabs module mat
icon module mat form field module and
matte select module
and now all of these imports we want to
include inside of our ng module
in imports array and for gauge module we
want to call for root
method the next thing i want to remove
some of the global styles which
are pretty default setup in angular
application
and i will set up some my own rules so
for the body i will use the roboto fun
family i will set this dark background
i will add some height and batting top
also i will set the same font family for
all the child elements of body
and reset the merging padding and box
sizing
and the last thing is that we want to
actually run our application
inside of terminal cd to our
folder directory into a root of our
application
and run ng server
and when this eventually starts our
application successfully we can head
over to
localhost 4200 to see our application
voila setup has been done now let's
start coding
first component which i want to create
is going to be search bar component this
component
is gonna stay on top of our application
for
searching the games so i want to head
over into
our app directory and make new one
called components all the components are
going to be stored here
for generating all components i'm going
to be using
angular cli so run the command ng
generate
component search bar
these are shorthand nggc
now once that has been generated i want
to
place that search bar component into our
main app component
so let's take the selector of this
component
and let's put it inside of our app
component first let me remove
all this boilerplate code from the app
components html file we don't need that
anymore
and i'll put search bar app search bar
selector there
that is our component now inside of the
app component.ts we don't need this
title
anymore so i will remove that and now
let's see how our component looks like
in the browser
and we can barely see it because of our
dark background but that's going to be
fixed
in no time i'll remove this boilerplate
code
from the search bar component and this
component is going to be very simple
i'm going to create on top of our
component search container class
div and inside of that we'll have a form
with a class of search form the next is
the logo actually and clicking on this
logo will redirect to the
home page so router link is going to be
a slash the next element
is our input element this one is going
to be used for actual
searching and it's going to have a class
of search input and the name of search
this one is going to
be used in our template and the last
element is our
submit button which is going to be a
class search button with the text of
search
once we click this button it's actually
going to submit
our form and we can take it from there
and this is how it looks without any css
so it's horrible let's apply some css
styles to it
first i'm going to create search
selector which is going to be the main
selector of our component
and inside of it it's going to be search
container first
with it's going to be full 100 with a
height of 60
background it's going to have this color
and also
we want to position this fixed so it's
always on top of our screen with
position of top
and left zero and z index one to be four
we want to align the items to the center
of that and this
starts to look a little bit better now
for our form
we want to set the width to be a hundred
percent and to set the max width
uh 1200 pixels because we want to
set the max width for our large screens
and to center it with margin zero auto
for our input margin is going to be 10
pixels on the left side
we're going to give some small padding
to 10 pixels width
it's going to be 300 pixels and we're
going to give a border radius to the
left side on the right side it's going
to be the button
and we want to reset the outline in
border to be none
for our button i'm gonna reset border
and outline to be none
background is set to blue padding to 10
pixels
also border left it's going to give some
small edge
on the right side we're going to set the
radius to 5 pixels
color is going to be white font weight
bold you're also going to give some
transition for the hover effect
and curse to be pointer
it looks better but it doesn't have any
hover effect so let's add that color is
going to be
blue and hover background is going to be
white and the border
is going also to be blue as well as the
color so it has some separation on the
left side
nice the last element of
our search bar which needs styling is
our logo so i will apply some margin to
the left side
color to reset to be white font weight
to be bold so it's
nice and separated cursor to be pointer
is it's going to be a link and text the
creation to be none
that's sweet now we want to handle
submitting of our form
and we are going to catch ng submit
event and we are going to create
onsubmit method which we will going to
be passing
our form as an argument inside of our
search bar component we want to inject
angular router as a dependency and we
will use this router to redirect our
application to our search page
which we will be building later on and
to pass in the value of our input field
from our form inside of our unsubmit
method we're receiving form as an
argument which is a type of ng form
and we're using this router to navigate
to a search
page which we'll be building later like
i said before
from the form which we are getting will
extract in the value
and the search which is actually from
our input
which is called the search as a name
also we want to import the missing
module which is ng form and router
from angular router
now let's test if this works let's just
type in some random text
and sub it now form to see do we get any
redirection
as if we check the console we can see
that it's getting the error
so as we haven't set up this routing yet
but it's redirecting to search
and once our search bar has been
completed i want to create our first
component
from our two components which we are
going to have in our application which
is home component
so we want to create new directory
inside of component directory which we
will call
home directory and then using angular
cli
i'm going to type in ng generate
component
home which will generate our new
component
then i want to create routes for this
component so inside of the
app routing.module i will create path
which will be default path and the
component will be home component
and also we want to all of our searches
to land on this page as well so we'll
add path
search slash game search which will be
our parameter
sent with our route so the component for
both
of these route is going to be home
component
and then the last thing is i want to
create router
outlet inside of our app component so
basically
all our components or actually the both
of our pages is going to be loaded in
this router
outlet and on top we will have this
search bar
and now if we check our application into
browser we can see that
home component has been loaded although
we can barely see it
as the text is dark the first thing we
want to
implement in our home application is
actually our filters
component which will be used for
filtering the games which
which are going to be displayed on home
page as we first initially when we
reload our application
it's going to have a lot of game cards
in it so we will create create a div
with a class of filters and we will use
mat form field
for our fields this is from angular
material
we'll use matte label and we will put a
label of sort
for uh our selection we'll use mat
select
uh component from angular material for
class we will set to be sort select so
that we can style it
will attach ng model sort so this is
going to be a variable from component
which will be attached to
matte select and we want to add some
values
so we will have value name released
added created updated rating and
metacritic
now to attach this math select we want
to create this sort variable
we just created inside of our html file
so we want to add that to our
home component ts file and once we
created that we can preview what we have
created in our home component as you can
see we have all the options
we just added but it's barely visible so
we need to add some styling
so let's head over to our home component
scss file
first let's select the filters class
which is a wrapper around our
mat select component so we will set the
max width to
match the containers with some margin
and also padding left so it's aligned
on the top navigation and the games
which we
will be creating later on so the next
thing is we want to use
ngdp selector this selector is used when
you want to select some of the
components which are generated from
for example matte matte select in this
case
so for my matte form field in fix we
will set the background color to be
this blue color so it's so it's actually
visible because right now it's
transparent
for for the following properties matte
select value
arrow for the placeholders and for the
form film
label we want to set the color to be
white and opacity
to one for matte form field infix we
will set the border color to be white
board top to be removed and padding left
to be 5 pixels
format form field label we want to set
it to to have padding left
five pixels so it's so it has some
padding on the text
and for the uh matte form field
underline so this is basically
an underline uh underneath the selection
we want to set the background color to
be white
and now let's preview what we got
okay the next thing which we want to
build is our actual game boxes
so first i want to create a wrapper for
our games
it's going to have class of games then
in this game's deal we will have all the
games
generated and loop through angular and
g4 but we will build that later
so first create a class game and inside
of that class you want to have an image
so it will have a div of class game
thumb container
inside of that container i will put an
image this image is going to have a
source
i just put some randomly picked image
from the web and it's going to have a
class of game
thumbnail so we can style it later then
i want to have a description below
the image and i will add a div with a
class of game description
and paragraph with a class of game name
so this will be the name of our
game actually and then on the bottom i
want to display all the platforms
which are supporting this game so they
will have a class of game platforms
and an image is going to have a class of
a game platform also
for the url i will put now just some
randomly picked image from the web which
but we will later on fill in all the
real data and that is going to be a slug
so let's preview what we have now as you
can see the image is
really large and you can and you can
barely see anything here
so let's apply some styles to this let
me head over to homecomponent.scss file
and first let's create games selector
which is for our wrapper
so i'm going to put display flex and
flex wrap
to be wrap so we want to wrap our
our boxes actually into uh three or four
we will decide later on
in a row justify content to be center
max width to be 1200 pixels
and to put margin 20 pixel auto
and those were stylings for our game
wrapper that hasn't been affecting a lot
our game box itself so let me set the
so it's like the selector of game for
our game box
the width of our games are going to be
280 pixels
margin is going to be that 10 pixels so
we'll have some margin
around our boxes height is going to be
330 pixels
everything will which overflows it's
going to be hidden
we'll have slight border radius of 5
pixels background color is going to be
dark
we'll have some slight yellow box shadow
so
and later on we will apply the hover
effect so once you hover over this box
it will expand so and we will add some
duration of transition so it has nice
animation and the cursor pointer
because eventually when you click on
these boxes it will
redirect to details page now let me
apply
this hover effect when we actually apply
uh when we actually hover over these
boxes
so box shadow is going to expand and
it's going to be it's going to move so
transform translate
y is going to be 3 pixels so it's going
to jump a little bit up
the next thing is we want to style our
thumb container
which is of our thumbnail or image
background color is going to be
black so this is for when we are missing
the actual image
the background color is going to be
black position is going to be relative
height 172 pixels color is going to be
white
and text is going to be align center so
we will display there is no
image once when when we actually don't
have an image for our game
and for the thumbnail itself we want to
position it absolutely
and to give top left and right zero
position and we want to set margin zero
auto so it's centered
also for the height we want to have 172
pixels
for description box we want slight
padding so 20 pixels
it's going to have display flex and flex
direction
is going to be column we want to justify
content to
flex end and height of 157 pixels
for our name or title of our game we
want color to be
white and bold font size to be 22 pixels
not nice and large
for margin bottom we want to have 20
pixels
white space is going to be no wrap so
that you know
you're not wrapping and we're applying
ellipses
of text which overflows so we have that
three dots if the text is too long
and it doesn't break the layout for our
platforms on the bottom
we want to have a display of flex
so they are all aligned and for our
platforms you want to have width of 20
pixels
and to have slight margin on the right
side
so at this point we are done at coding
html and csf
on our code page so now we want to
create our service which is which will
actually
fetch the url and the real data which
will be
fitting in to our home component so
first thing which i want to do is i will
create a services
folder and inside of that services
folder i will
create http service file using the
angular cli
so i will type ng generate service
and name for this service is going to be
http
and the angular cli is responsible for
injecting our service into our
application itself so we don't have to
do that manually
the thing which we want to do inside of
our constructor
in http service we want to inject the
http client which will be
dependency to communicate with our
backend
so the first method which i want to
create is get
game list so this is the method which
i'm going to be
calling from our home component and
fetching the list of the games
this method is going to receive two
arguments ordering and search search is
not going to be
required both of these are going to be
string and we are going to be re
returning observable api response game
this interfaces i'm going to be creating
later on
so first i'm going to create the
parameters for our method
and the default one is going to be
ordering so in order which we want to
sort the game list
and if a user is providing a search if
he's
typing in anything into our search box
we want to add append
also the search parameter as well and
the last thing we want to return the
http get method which will be returning
api response
this interface and the game interface
we'll be creating later
the base url of our service is going to
be created inside of the environment
file
and the route for this call is going to
be games
and we are setting the parameters of
params now let's create that base url
constant which we want to put inside of
the environments folder inside of the
environments file both
in those inside of the prod and whatever
the environment you have inside of your
application
and then we want to import that
environment
as an and it's a shorthand and to use
that
as our as sr url and now i want to
import
missing modules so observable
from rxjs and http params and now let's
create interfaces for our types api
response and game
so i will create new file which will be
called
models.ts and inside of that
file i want to export interface game
this is the
main interface which we'll be using to
define
our data so this interface is going to
have
types of background image name released
metacritic url website description
metacritic
genres this one is going to receive an
array of genre
we will create this interface later
parent platforms
also array of parent platform we will
create this one as well later
publishers array of publishers ratings
again array of ratings screenshots
it's going to receive the array of
screenshots trailers it's going to
receive
array of trailer so this all these array
interfaces
i'm going to create later on the bottom
the next one i want to create an
export interface api response
and t is a dynamic type so whatever type
we pass into our api response it will
return that as an array results of array
of data type
and now let's create the interface of
jar if we just have a name
now let's create interface of parent
platform it will have a
platform and a name property interface
publishers
is going to have a name property of type
string interface of rating
will have id account and title
interface interface of screenshots will
have image
of type string and the last one is
interface
trailer this one is going to have data
and max which is going to be a property
of type string
and now we created all the models we
need for our application
and which we are going to be using in
this
in this application now let's import
them into our service
so for api response and game
now in order to consume our api it's not
enough
just to set the url which we need so it
requires some of the parameters
and some of the headers to be attached
to our requests
so uh in order to do that i'm not going
to set up the parameters
and the headers to every single request
i'm going to do that on the application
level
so to do that i will use the
interceptors
so angular provides a way to do that on
the application level like i said before
the first thing which i want to do i
will create a separate folder for these
interceptors
the folder name is called obviously
interceptors and i'm going to create
three interceptors for our use cases
http
errors.interceptors.ts file this one
will be handling
the errors obviously the http
headers.interceptor.ts file
this one will be attaching the headers
which we want and the http
dash params dot interceptor.ts file
and this one is attaching the parameters
to our
requests so now inside of our http
errors
file i want to create an injectable
service and i'm going to export the
class of http
errors interceptor this class is going
to
implement our http interceptor
and we're going to have a constructor
empty constructor for now
and on all of these interceptor we need
to implement
intercept method from our http
interceptor interface
so this intercept method requires two
arguments first one is htv
request and the second one is http
handler
and it's going to be a returning
observable of
http event this is going to be type of
any
so we want to return of next which is a
handler for our request
with a method of handle and we're going
to
call a pipe which is going to catch an
error so
you want to do whatever you want in your
application but in my application
i'm going to log the error and i'm going
to be returning the observable throw
error so you can handle
however it suits for your needs and now
i will just import all the missing
modules from our file
and the quick import feature from the vs
code is really useful for
for this your purpose and the next
interceptor which i want to implement
is http headers interceptor all these
interceptors
are pretty much going to have like 90
the same uh
code we are implementing http
interceptor
uh interface and this class is going to
have a name http
headers interceptor so we also have
intercept method same as on the previous
one
but the body of the method is a little
bit different
so i want to clone the request and the
set the headers
in the headers i will set the two two
headers first one is rapid api
key and the second one is host and the
key host uh
instructions you will get on the public
api documentation where you will
register for free
and get all the tokens which you need
and i will put all the links
of this public api into description of
this video so that you can go and
register and follow along with me as
well
and also we can set actually on this
interceptor
the params as well so that we don't need
actually this http params interceptor
anymore so we
so i will remove actually that file and
i will put the params inside of a key
property in set headers
and at the end i will just return next
handle request
which is the request we just created so
it basically attached
all these headers to the previous
request which we cloned
and it just emits the attached
uh request with these headers and once
again
just import missing modules from you can
use visual studio code
quick import if you're using visual
studio code but pretty much
all the uh editors do have their import
uh features and now when we are done
creating our interceptors
uh we're actually not done we need to
insert them import them into our
application
so we need to go to app.module.ts file
and inside of the providers array we are
going to provide
these interceptors so i'm going to
create an object with the property of
provide
http interceptors use class http
headers interceptor this is the
interceptor we actually created
and i'm going to set the property multi
to true
and i'm gonna provide exactly the same
object for our
http errors interceptor and i'm gonna
import
these interceptors using quick import
feature of the visual studio code
now as we finally created our http
service and our interceptors
we want to start utilizing our service
and
the data actual data which we want to
get and the feeding into our page
so let's head over to home component the
component
which will be loading first initially
and
i want to create a public property of
games which will
be a type of array of games this is the
interface we created a couple steps
before in the constructor i want to
inject
http service this is the service we
created
just a couple seconds ago and i want to
inject activated route this is the
angular service
it is angular service we want in inside
of the ngo init lifecycle hook this is
the hook which
runs the first when your component
builds and
we want to use the activated route
params to subscribe to this event
this event returns the params which is a
type of params
and basically we want to check in uh we
will implement later when somebody
searches
our games to this query of search text
to be
attached to the url of our page so when
we actually load the page we want to
check
first here is there any game search
queries into our
url if there is we want to call a search
games method
this is the method which we are going to
create like in
in next couple of minutes so for this
method we we're going to send two
parameters and the first parameter is
going to be
the sorting and this public api lets you
choose couple of different
options like date when it's updated when
it's created and metagrid this is by the
rating
the rating methods and the second
argument is
game search this is the actual filtering
so
if there is a search query into our url
we will call this method with these
parameters
if there is no search queries into into
our url we want to just call
the search games with only sorting
parameter
and now let's create the search and
games method which will actually call
the api
and fetch these games this data so
search games method we will have will
have
two uh two arguments like we said before
first one is going to be sort and the
second one is going to be search second
one
isn't necessary isn't required so the
both of these
is going to be string type and the
return type of this method
obviously is going to be void so it's
not returning anything
so we are going to call the http service
and the get
game list method this method is the only
method we created into
our http service and this method accepts
two parameters
first one is sort and the second one is
search like we said we want to subscribe
to this event
and we are expecting back to get the
game list
which is going to be api response
the interface we created before and the
type is going to be the game
and when we get that result we want to
fit in
this game list property results into our
games
and i'm just going to log this result so
that we actually can see in our log what
we actually
got let's import all the missing modules
the same way as we did it before
and now finally if we go to our
application into browser
and if we open up the console
we can see the log object and if you
check
our results array we can see the actual
games
which we finally got so the next step
is to use these precious data and to fit
that
into our html and to make our page
finally dynamic
so that we get the games in our home
page
instead of this static content so let's
do that
and now inside of our html file of home
component you actually
can access the games variable which is
now
filled in with all the games which we
retrieve from from our api
so i'm going to create inside of the
games
div with a class of games i'm going to
create ngcontainer
and this container is going to be using
ng4
to loop through all the games and
display this play them basically
i will assign the variable of game for
each of these games
so first i want to check uh
if there is a game background image
property
so if there isn't we want to display a
paragraph
so i'm gonna assign ng if if it doesn't
have a background image
and i will just display text of no image
but if there is
a background image inside of our game i
will use that as a source
the next thing which i want to implement
i i want to
if there is a game name obviously every
game should have a name
so i will use game.name to to access the
property of name from our game
and then on the bottom we have a game
platform
so some of the games have multiple
platforms like playstation android xbox
a pc you name it so we are returning
this information as an arrays
so we want that once again when you use
when you're using arrays you want to
loop through these arrays and just
display them as a separate item so we
are using once again
ng4 to loop through game parent
platforms
and i'm going to create a variable name
game platform
to access these items so i have
downloaded uh from the web
different icons for the platforms you
can use whatever i mean style you want
but and i have created a folder inside
of the assets images platforms and
put all of these uh platforms over there
with the extension of svg
so this is the reason why i'm using this
url and i'm accessing
the property of game platform dot
platform dot slug to access this um this
url this is on my local
machine on my on my application and for
the alt of the image
i will just use platform.slog
and now we can go and preview what we
actually what we got now
so if you open the browser we can see
that finally we have multiple games so
we have
four games in a row and you can see this
we have this
nice images of the background we have
the names
the title names of the games and also
the various platforms
uh this looks interesting right yeah so
the next thing which we want to do here
so
as you can see this sword doesn't work
at the moment
so this is the thing which we want to do
we actually want when you choose some of
the
stored items we want to sort our games
based on these sorting items so i mean a
lot of things
could be done here we could obviously
improve like the loading we can
add pagination we can add infinite
scroll
a lot of things can be done but this is
like the basic thing how
how would you add some of the data into
your page how to make page dynamic
and yeah and now let's make this sort uh
select menu
actually working yep so what we want to
do
is in our mat select we want to catch an
event whenever our selection changes
so match like has a default event for
this and we want to
call certain action upon it so obviously
i want to catch that event and the name
is selection change
so when selection changes i want to call
a function
which is uh called search games this is
the function we already defined
inside of home component and this game
this
function we are calling on ngon init
already
passing some default uh values for
sorting
but now on every selection change we
want to pass in the sort
variable which is connected to our
selection menu and it's defined inside
of the home component
it's a public sort type of string so
every time the selection changes we will
pass in the new value which is updated
and our uh our games list is going to
get
updated as this is already connected and
hooked up so we should
see the changes right away so let's test
this out
and if we open our application now let's
see what we have there
so if we click on a sort and let's say
just whatever let's say released
and you can see that games has been
already updated i mean instantly so
let's choose something else
added
boom yeah so it gets updated right away
and
if we check the if we inspect our page
and go to network tab
and if you try to let
just another one we can see that the
request is sending
with the parameters of ordering and the
the thing which we actually selected so
in this case it's created so
yeah looks uh looks perfect and the
final thing which i want to do on a home
page so if you remember that i said
uh that we want to click on one of these
games
and one once we click it means that we
want to see more about
the game and we want to see more details
so what i want to do
is i want to bind new event uh on our
div game with the class of game
so i will buy the click event and i will
call a
method which will be named open game
details
and this event we will just create in a
second
to this event we will pass in a game id
so that we can open that game fetch the
api
and retrieve the more information about
this game
so now uh let we head over to home
component yes file
and that we created open game details so
first thing which we want to do
we want to uh reroute our application to
that new page
details page so we will need a router
for that and i will inject inside of the
constructor private router
which is a type of router so i will use
auto import from the visual studio code
and now let's create the game let's
create this opengamedetails method it's
really simple method
this method will receive an argument of
type of string it will be ide will
return return void so
we are not returning anything so we will
call this router which
which we just injected and we will
navigate to details page
and send in id as a parameter so the url
will be
our localhost then slash details and
then id
of our game and that's pretty much it
now it will give us error because we
haven't created that game yet so we will
do that in the next step
but before we finish everything i want i
want just to do a little bit of
refactoring
on our on our uh home component ds file
so
uh we have two uh subscribers which are
left hanging so we don't we don't want
that because we can
avoid some uh memory leaks so i want to
create two subscriptions
to watch out to our subscribers so on
top of our class
uh create route sub subscription and
game sub subscription
and inside of ng united lifecycle i will
sign routes up to
this activated route param subscription
and inside of our search game
i will assign this game sub to this http
service get games list
to this subscriber so we are
catching the subscribers in these two
variables and we want to implement
new uh on destroy lifecycle hook so
i will implement that inside of our
class
insert there and now we want to create
uh to implement engine destroy method
which actually implements on destroy
interface
so we want to check if this game sub
exists so if there is a
subscription existing we want to
unsubscribe this is when our
page is closing so that there is no any
memory leaks
and we want to check exactly the same
for route sub
we are checking if there is any routes
up uh subscription you want to
unsubscribe
and now i will just add on destroy uh
interface into our
class and import the missing modules for
the subscription and the router
and we're good to go to go and implement
our details page let's start doing that
first let me create a details page and
inside of components folder i will use
angular angular cli to generate new
component
so just type in command ng generate
component
details and once that is generated
it's connected to our application
inserted automatically and i want to go
into app routing.modules file and there
i will create a new route for our
details component so
that new path will be detailed slash
uh column id so this is the id which we
are going to get in the url
which which we are sending from our home
page and we are catching that
idea of the game which we're which we'll
be using for
uh showing the details of our games so
the path is
detailed id which is going to be
a number and then component is going to
be details component
and then we just need to import that
component
and now let me test this new route which
we just created so
open the browser again in our
application and if we click on any of
the games
we should get the details new route and
the id of this
this game and you can see that detail
works this is the html code of our
new component so the route works
perfectly we just need to
start uh coding and put the details of
our game in html
code so let's start doing that on the
very top i will create a deal with the
class of details so we'll so this will
be the main class
of our page and then on the top we want
to have a banner big banner with the
image of our game
so i will create another div with the
class name a game banner
so inside of this banner we'll have this
image and the class of the image
is game better image i will put some
random image
for now but later on we will make this
dynamic and for dalt i'll put background
image
and this is for accessibility purpose
and below that below the game banner we
want to
create new div with a class name of game
content inside of this
div we're going to display more
information more details about this
game that is the reason why user wants
to actually navigate to this page
so uh i will click i will create uh
another with a class named details
wrapper
and inside of that tip i will create
another one
with the class uh game header so this is
this is going to be a header
of our content and below we will have uh
tabs actually because it's going to be
more
um nicely
laid out if we have the tabs on our page
so
inside of uh game header we want to have
a title
uh and i will create a h1 tag with a
class name game header title
and i will just put game name here for
now uh
below that we want to have a issue tag
and the class will be game header
release date
so we'll have our release date here and
below that we want to have a
john of our game so class well i will
create a paragraph of class
game header genres and inside of that uh
span
but i will just put rpg for now this is
also of course
going to be a dynamic and then on on the
right side we want to
display uh graphical dis the
representation of our
rating of our game so i'm using the
plug-in mvl
gauge so i will create a div
with the class name game gauge and
inside of that i will put our
extension so we will have a couple of
properties here
so i will put
i mean i don't have to explain all of
these properties but you can see we're
setting the class
the max of course this is the max rating
uh
start and end angle of our gauge
then the value we're gonna put the game
rating so this value is going to be
a variable which we are going to define
right away
on our class details component so
uh it's going to be zero it's going to
start at zero
and then when you fetch the data it's
going to animate to the
value which we which we retrieved from
the api
animated obviously we want that to be
true then
color uh we are gonna create a function
gut color so
color will be changing depending on the
value which we're getting
so inside of details component the ts
file
i'll create a new method named get color
and this method is going to receive a
value which is the type of a number so
this is uh
the value we're passing in from our
widget and the return type is going to
be a stirring so we are returning back
the color which we just is going to be
using to display the color
on their bar so if the value is above
the 75 so it means
the rating is good and we want to return
this color which represent the green
color
then else if the color is the value is
lower than 75 but it's greater than 50
so we want in that case to return this
is the orange
color and if the value is less than 50
but
greater than 30 we want to display this
yellowish
color and for everything else below the
30
we want to display the red color which
means that game is
bad so the rating is terrible
and that's with our get color
function and then we want to set the
animation duration i will set two
seconds so it's nice
slow and uh it can catch the user's
attention
yeah and on the bottom uh of this
uh of this uh widget we want to place
uh anchor tag uh with the class name
game gadget label
and the target is going to be underscore
blank so we want basically to put a link
here to
our rating where the rating has took to
place on
metacritic website and that is for our
header
of our content uh below that you will
have uh tabs
material tabs and we will store that in
a separate
component which we'll be generating uh
just in a second but first
let's first style what we got here
and let me first preview what is our
html how it looks like and then we can
style all of that and continue with our
tabs
so we have this big image which will be
our
background image but it needs to be
sized better
and our title game title i mean it's
very
simple we have release date we have
darjean
this is our plugin for rating so it's
zero at the moment
and yeah and this is metacritic link so
uh this is how it looks like now let's
style
so inside of our details component uh i
will create a details wrapper
selector and uh this is a wrapper which
i have created the same on our home page
so max width is going to be
900 pixels and the margin 20 pixels auto
so this is to center our content
and to give slide separation on top and
bottom
so position is going to be relative as
we are going to have a
image floating and to be positioned
absolutely so
inside of our details div i want to
start first
our widget for the rating i'm i'm going
to use ngdp selector angular selector
for the
elements inside of uh as a child
components
so this is the basic elements which are
be generated
compiled at the runtime the width and
the height is going to be 150 pixels and
this space is going to be block
and slide padding to 10 pixels for the
dial
and this is a width of our stroke so
it's going to be
10 and for the value i want to set
dash right to be none and the stroke
width to be 13.
and then for our value text this is the
text
which at the moment shows zero so the
color will be
white weight is going to be bold and one
side
24 pixels for our game garage
dev position is going to be absolute we
are going to position it
top 50 pixels and on the right side zero
and for our label which says metacritic
font size is going to be 20 pixels color
white position relative and at from the
bottom 60 pixels
now we want to style the game div and
for the banner
uh the height is going to be 442 pixels
and overflow hidden
for the image we want to be the full
with
and to blur a little bit so that the
text is separated from the background
for the content we want to center it and
position relatively
and to move a little bit on uh i mean
200 pixels on top
because we want the text to be on the
background
on the banner so for the header title
i'm going to set this huge font size and
to set the color to be white also to be
bold
and to set the line height to be the
same as the font size
and i don't want it to wrap so white
space no wrap
for the release date also the color uh
white and the font weight bold and for
john is the same
and that's what we're going to do for
our top part
and now we want to grab our data and to
make this page dynamic
so inside of our details component es
file i want to create
a couple of variables first so game id
this is the id which which we are going
to be retrieving from the route
type is string uh the variable game this
is the
variable which is going to hold all the
data of our game so the type is going to
be a game this is the
custom type which we created inside of
our models
file and then two subscriptions for
because we are going to have two
subscribers on our page so route sub
subscription and game sub subscription
now we want to
inject a couple of dependencies inside
of our constructor so
the first one is activated route uh it's
going to be private of course
and the type is activated route so this
dependency
basically uh provides you with the api
of the route
once it's activated and the private http
service this is the service
uh custom service which should be
created to communicate with our api
so now we want to create uh inside of
ngo and in it
basically we want to we can assign our
subscription to
our route sub and we can
call this activated route params
subscribe so we are subscribing to our
params
and we are getting back the params which
is a type of params
so we want to assign to our game id what
is sent
to our parameters through our details
slash id url
so we are assigning this game id equals
params id
and then we will use this id to pass
into our
uh our method which we are which we are
cr we are going to create in a couple of
seconds
this game details and we are passing uh
this game id
so let's define this method get game
detail so it's going to receive
id which is type of string and we're not
going to return here anything it's type
of void
so here we're going to have another
subscription so we are assigning this
game sub to our subscription so that we
can later on clear
all these subscriptions once the details
page is closed
so we are going to call the http service
and
this method doesn't exist yet but we are
going to create that one
in a second get game details and we are
going to pass
in this parameter id which we're getting
from the
route uh we're gonna subscribe to that
and from the response we should get a
game
the actual game which we want yay and we
will just
pass in to our game a game response
and actually we want to update our game
rating
uh if you remember that we have that
widget for displaying animated rating of
our game so i want to set us
time outside that the user has some time
to load the page and to
sit a little bit delayed so i will set a
timeout
and i will assign this game rating to
this game metacritic so this rating
after one second yeah and now i will
just import all the missing modules uh
from our file using quick import feature
of the visual studio code
and now we want to define this game
details
method inside of our service because we
don't have that created yet so
let us head over to http service ds file
and inside of this file let me create
this method
so the name is game details get game
details
the parameter which is reserving is the
retrieving is the id
of our game so id is type of string and
we're returning observable of type game
so we will have uh three requests here
because
actually we are combining uh all all the
information from these
three requests into single one so we
will define
three constant game in for request and
the url of this
get request is our base url slash game
slash id
so this here we will get the majority of
information
then we want to trailer so we will
display video
trailers on our page so this request is
for that so
constant game trailers request equals
http
get method and the url is space url
games slash id slash movies and the next
one is we want to display some
screenshots of our game so
the next one is this http get base url
slash game slash id
screenshots and now we want to use a
fork join to retrieve all of these
uh get methods and combine them
into one so i'm passing gaming info game
screenshots again trail
game trailers request and i'm using pipe
to map
this response um so i'm returning one
object and um i'm gonna use
uh the old information uh i'm gonna use
spread operator to use all the
properties from our gaming for request
and i'm going to create two additional
properties screenshots and trailers
to fade in the results of the additional
two requests which we are getting so
we'll get
everything but we need inside of this
get request
and the last thing of course is to
import all the missing modules again
and now we can head over to details
component html file
and inside of the source of the image we
will change this to be
game background image so we're going to
implement now
our data for our title we're going to
set the game
dot name property for a name
then for the release date i'm going to
use game.released
and here i'm using datepipe to
to format our output format of our date
so this is a pipe which formats uh the
html for our needs or strings
now for genres as we can have more of
these
i will use ng4 to loop through the array
which we're retrieving
and i will set the last uh index
so we will need last index in order to
uh
display the commas so for for name i
will use genre
names name and then i will use ng if to
see if the last
only for the last you you don't want to
display comma obviously
so for all the others we want to display
comma
then i want to the last thing is for our
label
we want to set the url of the review
where it has been
order rating so i will set the game
metacritic url
and now as you can see this rating bar
is animating nicely and we have attached
the metacritic urls
here so if you click on it it actually
gets us to their
site and you can see the breakdown of
this rating and get more information
about
how they got to this rating uh the name
obviously game name has been cooked up
in the release date so we're using
datepipe here to you know format this
but you can use
whatever format you want as long as
you're you're using a datepipe
and at the bottom we have the genres so
as you can see the comma is not in the
last place
so the next thing which we want to do is
we want to build the bottom part of
this page and provide more information
so i will be using uh
single material tabs for this element so
let's call that
but before we actually hold this we want
to do a little bit of pre-factoring
on our details component page so i want
to clean up all the subscriptions once
the component is destroyed again
the same thing which we did on the home
component so i'm gonna implement
on and destroy and destroy uh lifecycle
hook
and uh i will create ng on destroy
method to implement that
the return type is void obviously and
i'm just going to check if there is a
game sub
and if there is i'm going to unsubscribe
and the same thing for the
route sub and then i'm just going to
import
on destroy uh interface and
that's done now let's let me create
using angular cli
or tabs component and inside of the
terminal i want to open our directory
source app component
and i will type in ng generate component
game tabs and once that is generated
i just want to head over to our details
component html page and
on the very bottom i want to include
this
app game type tabs so
let me preview is that hookup correctly
and as you can see
it is so now we want to head over to our
newly created app game tabs uh component
and want to start coding
uh all the details we want to display on
this we're gonna have three tabs so you
will see in a bit
so on very top of our game tabs dot
component.html file
i'm creating uh div with the class name
game tabs
so this is our main wrapper then i'm
creating mat tab group
this is the group of our tabs using
angular material
metal line tabs is going to be start and
the background color is primary so
the color is going to be the color you
choose for a theme when you install them
in your material uh first tab which i'm
going to create
is a mat tab labeled about so
we're going to have about screenshots in
trailer section
so in in our about section uh on very
top i will
create a paragraph game tab spare and
the label is going to be platforms and
here we're going to list all the
platforms of our game so for now
i'm going to put the pc underneath uh
i'm going to create another paragraph
game tabs pair with the label of
publishers
and here we're going to display
obviously publishers so i will put
konami
underneath i want to create another
paragraph
game types power so all the classes are
going to be the same
for these paragraphs the label for this
one is going to be a website so we want
to
link a website to a game if there is any
inside
of a paragraph i will put a link anchor
link with the class name games apps link
href is going to be a pound now and
target underscore blank so we open that
in a new browser
in a new tab and uh i'm going to leave
that without a link for now
then we want to put some a description
of the game so i will put another div
with a class a game description and put
some random text
and below that i will create new
paragraph with a claim a video class
game to have
votes so we want to have a voice of our
game every game has a votes in a rating
so
i will create two icons uh
with the game with thumbs up and thumbs
down so i will use
uh two spans so span
and then i will use matte icon which we
included with the angle material
class name for this one will be games
game votes
up and uh icon text is
thumb up and uh we want to display the
count
of the thumbs up so span
uh will be class name game votes count
and here i'll just put some random
numbers so same thing we want for the
games thumb down
uh but the class name will be game votes
down
and obviously the icon will be thumb
down
so this is a font icon and you just put
in the text
and you get the icon so this is the icon
for the thumb down
and i think that's all what we want to
hear for about label
about tab so let me preview what we got
okay uh that looks ugly for now but we
will start
in a bit so for the second tab uh it's
going to be a screenshot this one is
going to be very very simple so we're
just going to have an image
and the image is going to have a class
name of game
screenshot so we'll have multiple
screenshots but for now it's going to be
just this one for source i will put a
link
from the web and i'll i'm just going to
put a screenshot
and the last tab is uh trailers tab and
as you can see
uh here we're going to display some game
trailers and
so i will create a video html tag with a
clay stamp
class name of game trailer and i'll put
controls as well so the user can
navigate uh source is gonna be just
random video
right now but we're gonna implement that
later on type is going to be
video mp4 and we're just going to
display text your browser doesn't
support video tag if you're using some
older browsers and finally let me
preview what we created so as you can
see we have tabs
and we just need to style it a little
bit better and
apply some styles to screenshots and
trailers as well so
let's do that inside of the
game tabs components a css file so i'll
create a
main game selector on top and all the
styles are going to be inside of this
selector
so uh dash tabs for the
game tabs selector we want to set the
background
then we want to set the color to be
white to align all the text on the left
side and
give some slight padding for all the
paragraphs we want to so
game types power we want to get some uh
padding and to
get the margin bottom to be zero so that
we don't have any separation on the
bottom
for the links we want to set only color
to be white so as our background is dark
we want all the colors to be
all the text colors to be white so for
the votes
i will give some margin on the left side
and display flex so they're all
aligned and for the count i will give a
slight
margin on the left side so it's 5 pixels
and for the labels i want just to
center centrify them so justify content
center
for our votes i will put the colors
obviously for
what's up i will put this green color
and for the votes down the color is
going to be this red one
and for the counts uh we want just to
keep a slight separation
on the left on the right side on the
right side is going to be 10 pixels
because i want to separate
both down and votes up a little bit and
to
align them a vertical line is going to
be super so they're like in the middle
for our text description i'm just going
to set
this padding to be 20 pixels and that's
it then for
screenshots uh i want to give a little
bit margin on top
so it's uh five pixels then for the
width i want to give it
uh 50 minus 10px because
we want to display two screenshots in a
row so this is why the width is 50
pixels minus
10 pixels is going to be our
margin so on every even child and child
even
we want to set the margin left to be 10
pixels so that we only have the
separation
in the middle and for our trailers we
want to
have a width 100 so the full width and
to give it just slight margin on top and
the bottom
and with that i'm happy with the results
what we have for now so
the next thing which i want to do is i
want to connect the data to
your html page so to our html code
so we actually have fetched already our
uh all the information which we are
going to be
uh displaying here and the information
is inside of our details component
inside of the game variable so what we
want to do inside of this child
component this game tabs component
inside of our ts file we want to create
a new input
so this is the input property which will
be receiving
uh the information so input is going to
have a name of game and type
of game so this is the game interface
which we created before so i'm going to
import that
and then inside of our details component
inside of the html5
file we want to add a property input
game
and to pass in our game so this is the
way how to
share the data between the parent and
child components so we're just
setting up the input and we're passing
in our game
so at this point we have all the
available information inside of our game
tabs and now we just want to go and to
hook up that inside of our html file so
let's do that
so first thing which i want to do is on
our game platforms i want to check
if there is any platforms at all so that
we don't display this
platform's label if there isn't so i'm
setting up ng
if game platforms dot length so if it
exits
if the length is more than a zero so if
it is
i'm gonna use uh ng4 for looping to
right
through our array of platforms i'll let
game of game parent platform so i'm
using i'm setting up this game variable
half our platforms and i'm just gonna
use the lat
uh last so that we detect which one is
lacks
last so that we don't display the comma
on the last item
so i will just put in the game platform
the name so the name of our platform
and uh after that i will just
set ng if if it's not the last element
set the comma if it's last element don't
display this comma into our array
so similar similar thing i want to do
for publishers as well so we'll check if
there is any
publishers if there is the length grade
of zero
if there is i want to loop through our
game publishers array
and i will set the variable uh let
publishers
again i'm gonna use the last index and i
will from publishers as well i'm just
using
name so again i'm checking if it's not
the last element
display the comma if it is don't display
this comma
then for our game website again i will
check if there is a game website
website property if it's not so that we
don't display this website
a label i will put
inside of href game website which is the
link of the website
and i will display exactly the same text
so i will put inside of the brackets
game website
so it will display the link the url
inside of the text for the for the game
description i will use the inner html
input and i will just pass in the game
description so we'll
so this will just put in the raw text
now for the ratings the ratings uh i
will
as we are also getting the the array
return type so i will loop
using the ng4 because we can have
multiple ratings
usually it's just it's just a one but we
can have multiple them
so i will assign the variable rating
from game
dot ratings array and i will check
we get uh multiple ratings and i will
just display the two ones
so the first one is exceptional so i'm
checking ng if
if the rating title is equal to
exceptional so this is like the top
we will display our thumbs up and
we want to use the variable account so
from rating dot count
if there is no count you want just to
display zero
and then afford our thumbs down i want
to use
the rating skip so basically if user has
rated game as a skip
uh we want to display the thumbs down so
rating title is equal to skip
and again we're using rating count for
this rating as well and if it's not
i'm gonna just set up the zero then i
want to check if there is
screenshots at all so ng if game
screenshots
length if it's greater than zero we want
to display tabs sometimes we don't have
screenshots so
we don't want to display this tab at all
and if we have a screenshot we want to
loop
through the array of screenshots and
display the image so i will use
ng for last screenshot of game
screenshots
so in the screenshot i will just use the
image
for our source and that will loop and
display all the
source images this can be optimized i
mean
sometimes to display just uh above the
fold of the page so it's uh so it
doesn't load all
images before it's seen but we will
leave it like this for now
and the last tab is our trailers and the
same thing as a four screenshots i will
check if there is uh
any trailers because uh trailers as well
are not
displayed for every game so ng if game
trailers length is greater than zero
obviously
so we'll we want to loop through the
game trailers array
i will set the variable that trailer and
just going to loop
and then just in the source uh input i
will put
trailer data max which is actually
the max resolution we want to display
the trailers of the max resolution that
is the property they used
and now let your preview that is the all
the data which will be hooking up in our
in our games
component so let me preview what we
actually got
and now if you refresh our page you can
see that uh on the about section
the platforms are now hooked up array
and as you can see
the commas are just for the elements
which are not the last
so the platforms are displayed correctly
publishers rockstar games so
this looks good for the website it's
hooked up
to their website and you can click them
it redirects you to a new tab
so this is this looks awesome and uh
below that we have the description
and as you can see the ratings yes look
i mean they look okay to me there is a
lot of
thumbs up so this is very very popular
game so if you look on the screenshots
tab
that is nice we have uh loaded these
screenshots so
it gets you in a row this nice matching
circulation
and for the last one with the trailers
uh actually for this game we have
multiple trailers so let me see
yeah i'm not gonna play them longer but
as you can see it looks correct so this
basically wraps up
our application so we have we have built
everything from scratch
so just to sum up we have this homepage
which loads our games by default
on metagrader ratings so and we can
build this search on top so if
you type in some game let's say soccer
july soccer you can get the preview of
the games
also except sorting so it's probably
quite released or any other
uh criteria so that looks nice also if
you want to check
more about the game itself you can click
any of the games
and we load up the details game
and you can see as well
and uh for this game you can see now
there is no trailer so it doesn't
display with the last
tab but it displays screenshots clicking
and about section as well so
that's it
[Music]
you